names been important I'm 27 years old
I'm a photographer originally I went out
to Costa Rica to film a documentary for
the Costa Rican government and while I
was out there we saw the shark poaching
going on
when I came back to the US and started
thinking about it more I realized that I
really wanted to do something I wanted
to create change I've always had a
connection of the ocean and seeing it
just being torn apart out there I knew I
could do something with photography
sharks are the most important species in
the ocean and they're one of the most
ancient if we lose sharks the entire
ocean will be off balance what I was
doing this expedition is showing the two
most biologically important places for
these animals for me the stories that I
love the most stories that contrast
animals with people underwater with the
bubbler stories that combine the
different parts of photography that I
love
when you can give somebody the
experience of living vicariously through
an image and combine that with the
science and data that's done by the
scientist that's the strongest
combination that's what creates change
it generates a connection
everybody has their own medium whether
it's writing music computers or artwork
use it to create change